I don't even know where to start with
this mess New Year's Eve alright so in a
world where bigger is better how do you
one-up the movie Valentine's Day you
know that rom-com that relied heavily on
biggish actors playing small roles in
the movie oh I know you make a movie
like New Year's Eve a movie that relies
more on biggish actors playing large-ish
roles in it there's so many people in
this movie and none of them matter
seriously though look at that cast
that's a lot of people and what are the
people doing the movie will stuff that's
pretty much how I can describe it a lot
of I'd say b-list actors do things
there's a couple of big hitters in this
movie like Robert DeNiro yeah he came on
screening at a point when he came on
screen I was just like oh not Robert De
Niro yeah it's kind of like that there
are so many characters in this movie
it's like when everyone's special that
means no one is I mean you have like 20
storylines in this movie and the thing
that this movie suffers from the most is
basic economics this movie has flooded
the market with characters there's so
many characters in this movie that the
value of a character has dropped its
basic economics and it's the downfall of
this movie it has so many characters
doing so many different things it even
has the guy and the girl stuck in the
elevator bit they did that when they did
I was like oh not the stuck in the
elevator but no and it happened but that
chick from Glee's she's really hot she's
in this movie she's wearing a hot dress
too in fact you know she makes the dress
look hot she's she's pretty she's pretty
nice doesn't change the fact the movies
still this movie I will take to romantic
comedy storylines that actually matter
rather than the 20 that you get in this
movie that just don't and in the end of
the movie everything's coming together
and these people are connected to these
people and didn't know these people were
going to be connected with these people
and that was kind of interesting and
then I wanted to punch myself anywhere
on my body yeah you take the graph of
the human body I would punch myself
anywhere in that part just for caring I
hated myself for even caring where these
characters were going because it didn't
matter I mean it has to touch on so many
characters that by the time you've
wrapped back around to touching on the
character that they touched on you know
a half an hour prior you're like oh yeah
I totally forgot about these characters
that's how much I care and that happens
to everyone you're like oh I forgot
about them I forgot about them I forgot
about them by the time it wraps back
around to that first character you're
like I forgot about them all over
that's like I said before it's like
someone took the script for this movie
shredded it up put it in the barrel of a
shotgun and stuffed it with a bunch of
characters that were going to be in this
movie and shot it at a wall
all right connect the dots however you
want that's going to be this movie there
were a couple of girls in this movie I
asked him I was like what did you think
of this movie they were like it could
have been better which his chick speak
for it was [ __ ] actually know what
there was a funny part of the movie the
best part of the movie the end credits
and I'm not just saying that like oh the
movie sucked the end credits with the
best Parkins movie was over I'm saying
in the end credits they had bloopers and
outtakes and there were a hundred times
funnier than the previous two hours of
the movie I mean it was genuine it was
real it was funny I liked the end
credits should end two hours of end
credits it would have been gold in any
case your new year's resolution yeah I
know it's a little early for New Year's
but you know what what is your
resolution going to be comment below let
me know might as well talk about what
you're probably not going to hold up to
yeah me too I do that kind of [ __ ] in
any case if you liked what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more but you only have to
put up with one douchebag character and
that is enough
[Music]